[Music]
luke fickle is the head coach at
cincinnati he joins us now coach how's
morale on campus today
it's pretty good i think we had meetings
this morning and uh it wasn't really
brought up or talked about but uh i'm
not uh saying they don't understand they
don't know but uh outside of our offices
i'm not really sure how the uh how the
community out there is really feeling
okay but let's let's try to figure out
what the reasoning is
because you're gonna have to your kids
are gonna wanna know you know that
boosters fans they're gonna wanna know
like why are we on the outside looking
in you've done everything that you're
supposed to do even though you had a
close game against navy and maybe you
didn't dominate to lane the way you
should or whatever their reasoning is
um
so why do you think you guys are sixth
right now
that's what i leave to you guys you guys
uh do a lot better job at talking about
it and given uh maybe ideas and reasons
and things like that for us within the
program it's really difficult to you
know spend a whole lot of time trying to
figure out exactly why like you said i
heard you before this is the first
ranking it's not the last one there's a
lot of games to be played we got a lot
of work to still continue to do
i think there's still a lot of
opportunities so uh where it does
generate a buzz i think that's the
biggest thing about college football is
the talk in the last six weeks of the
season creates a lot of energy um you
know so i kind of for us in our program
i said guys let's leave it to the
experts out there to figure out as to
why and and project who might be and
let's just try to handle our own
business what did you think of my
reasoning that maybe they left you out
because they don't want you to stay in
you go undefeated and then they have no
reason to take you out
maybe a good idea you know i think that
it gives them a little flexibility a
little leeway i don't know exactly who
makes all these decisions uh i think
they do look down the
the stretch and see hey they've got some
really good games coming up um if they
get into a championship game obviously
it'll be another ranked team so i think
that gives you some abilities and they
also know what other people are playing
so i don't know if they really look that
far and strategize or do they just throw
things out there to create a little bit
more of a buzz and something to talk
about i'm not sure and i'm wondering
about this because i've said this before
it's not like cincinnati is a great
football program but you've had pockets
there you've certainly done a great job
but you've got to go play somebody it's
it's it's you're not going to get these
big schools are going to go we're going
to go to cincinnati and play you you you
said we'll play anybody anywhere we'll
go to notre dame we don't care
um who have you tried to schedule you
just can't you can't get them on the
schedule
i don't know i to be honest with you
this is year five and uh truly for the
first three and a half years i said guys
you do whatever you want i'm not worried
about the scheduling uh i've got to do a
lot of we got a lot of work to do to
start before we start worrying about the
scheduling i think last year was the
first year they even started to ask
about some scheduling stuff that i
wanted to talk about and uh i don't know
i mean who they've reached out to and
different things like that i know that
going into the season having notre dame
have an indiana on the schedule two top
ten ranked teams um was something that
you know not only excited us but you
know for the talking heads gave an
opportunity to say hey if they have any
chance at least they've got some top 10
teams already on their schedule
should
we look for style points in college
football that it's not just winning in
the nfl you just win in college football
it's well you won
but
oh i think obviously in the nfl there's
a lot more parity that's the way the
thing is designed to be college football
well i'd say there's not nearly as much
parody but it comes down to a lot more
of not just who the best teams are uh
it's who's playing the best and each and
every week i think that's for me what we
try to evaluate and uh i think the great
thing that they will do in college
football and i think they have done and
i think they get it from from the
basketball side of things is let's
really try to hone in on these last five
weeks and say but as that stretch goes
who's playing the best football because
ultimately we gotta we gotta find the
right if it's four if it's six if it's
eight however many they end up going to
obviously this year it's four we need to
find the four teams that we believe are
playing the best football in the last
three four or five weeks of the season
yeah and i pointed this out to the
audience uh earlier in the show
you know you'll play anybody you played
georgia but that was in a bowl game and
you guys should have won that game i
thought you were guys with the better
team there so it's not one of those
where they go yeah there's a big
drop-off between georgia and cincinnati
and i said not as much as you think
because you got a talented quarterback
you got a couple of guys on defense are
going to play in the nfl
uh how did you feel after that game
against georgia as far as talent to
talent matching up with one of the best
in the country
well i mean obviously i think the game
dictated a lot of that i think we've
gained some confidence i think in how we
can match up um you know not saying that
we didn't have some opportunities last
year was a unique year that you didn't
really play any too many out of
conference games to kind of find out
maybe where you are sometimes going into
your you know conference season um but i
think i think what it made a lot of
people recognize is you can't hang with
the the blue bloods the top five the top
ten if you don't have legitimately
sometimes you can play some good
football and you can keep some games
close but to truly truly have a chance
to beat those top five programs in the
country you gotta have some talent of
your own you've gotta have a you know a
dynamic quarterback you got to be able
to play some you know complimentary
football and i think to me as people
continue to watch i think that's what i
want them to see from you know our
program and what we are is yeah we might
not have all the stars that uh georgia
has or or alabama has but you know it's
a lot about development you see these
three four f fifth year guys that
are playing really good football and
have a lot of opportunities even play at
the next level
well
are you going to say that anything to
the kids today does this topic come up
uh you know what i mean at the end of
practice we'll uh we'll make sure we we
bring it up and and i'm one of those
guys that you know didn't watch the show
did i went to my radio show last night
and still had no idea it was eight
o'clock radio show i had no idea had not
seen the uh seen any of the the results
had not heard about it didn't want to
know um but i also don't want to bury my
head in the same because i know our kids
it matters and it means something too so
we try to find a way that hey we're
gonna make sure we're not ignoring
what's going on but hey look how can we
use it to continue to motivate us
and you may get more publicity coach by
being sixth
instead of four
like almost positive publicity like oh
my gosh if you were four you'd have a
lot of people say oh they don't deserve
to be four but when you're six it's like
you don't deserve to be six you're
getting screwed
so i guess you gotta find a way that's
uh it benefits you the most and i think
when you're dealing with 18 to 22 year
olds it's 90 psychological and you say
okay now with whatever happened there
how do we kind of frame it make sure our
guys understand that we got to use this
in the best way possible uh do you have
your standard response when you're asked
about other job
openings pretty much do yeah let me let
me hear it let me hear it so coach you
know your former athletic director is at
uh usc and uh you interested in that
that job opening
it's a great tribute to our players i
tell you what what they've done on the
football field has given us all
opportunities we got plenty of young
guys that are getting calls as juniors
to leave early and uh that's because of
the people that are around them the how
they've developed um you know so when we
look at it when people bring those
things up whether it's me or our
coordinators we say hey it's all because
of the program the team and what they've
done all right let's go around the room
how did coach do with that paulie guys
we like it he credited the players and
went right to the players that's
original yeah but it's a distraction
he's trying to take it away from him put
it on the kids
uh seat what did you think of coach i
thought it was well played well done
okay
remember i i
yeah yeah i coached for i coached for
jim tressel for 10 years and there's
nobody that was better at finding a way
around questions and diverting them and
making sure he could say what he really
wanted to say i did learn a little bit
from him yes mclevin yeah i signed me up
to play do you need a backup punter
coach
you don't know where you're going are
you going to cincinnati are you going to
los angeles yes todd that was remarkably
vague and smooth and classy
uh if you uh you know win the national
title i'll come back i'll be in the
parade there coach
i appreciate we will have you for sure
thank you coach we appreciate your time
all right dan thank you that's luke
fickle cincinnati head coach they got
tulsa coming up don't sleep on houston